I'll be the greatest president I'm gonna
be get Daniel trunk sound chump it's
gonna be yet it's gotta be good
hey everyone my name is Matt bellezza
and welcome to the first snazzy new
episode of season 2 of whine about it
for those of you who don't know whine
about it is a weekly video series where
I get drunk in my desk and complain
about stuff and on this the first
episode of our brand new season today's
topic is the worst things about
Halloween
let's drink I'm not gonna mess around
this season we're gonna get right into
it all right first of all Halloween
encourages children to be bigger piles
of hot garbage than they already are
what kind of [ __ ] holiday teaches
children it's okay to come to my door
and ask for free food any other day if a
kid came to my door asking for candy
dressed as a monster I'd mace them right
in the face right in the chubby little
face I don't care how old you are you
aren't candy
why don't you get a job then you go down
to the CVS and like the cashier right in
the face while you buy a whole bag of
jumbo KitKat's for yourself all right
that's how adults get candy why are you
trying that instead next bite-sized
candy whoever invented bite sized candy
probably invented a whole bunch of other
dissapointed things like 4-inch dildos
or grapes with the seeds of them still
or Switzerland what's the point
look at this what kind of hole is this
gonna fill huh not this one not today
give you a big candy bar you know I'll
show you something real special then
there's all those old ladies who give
out pennies or fruit instead of candy if
you're not going to give out candy you
need to move up on the free food
hierarchy
not down how about a nice glazed ham
with a side of mashed sweet potatoes
ever thought about that say to your
penny how about it how about a warm
jambalaya your apple if i were an apple
like go down to the barn
steal the steel from the horses that's
where I get my apples next Halloween
parties how many parties are sweat
disgusting sweaty thigh slamming messes
everybody used to dress like spider-man
little princesses and now look at
everyone our wood does is get drunk and
sweaty and try to get their chut see
roles so tickle some Laffy Taffy's just
rubbing around their pieces of candy
more on one another if I wanted to watch
a Dora the Explorer grind up on a
SpongeBob SquarePants I go I go right on
the Internet you find that you find it
right on the Internet
all right I've seen it I don't need to
see that in person
yes also bros who try too hard to show
off her glistening tan meat bags all
right we get it
you drink a protein shake once but if I
see one more fraternity brother dresses
that guy from 300 just so we can show
off his left
tak I'll take out my earrings I'll slap
a bit right across the face that is
sparta and finally candy corn candy corn
is Satan's hardened earwax the only
people who like candy corn are people
who eat hard-boiled eggs with a little
bit of a shell on them still that's the
kind of people who we can be
the people bring candy corn into our
office like it's some kind of good
delicious treat weird yeah I don't want
your candy corn alright everybody thank
you for watching this week as always you
can find our videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com and my page
which is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt
everybody gets how